hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into
practice I've studied and taught
Philosophy for over 20 years and I find
that many people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured but the
concepts themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them
useful what you're currently watching is
part of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on One Core concept
from an important philosophical text I
hope you find it useful as
well near the end of the conclusion in
part three of his proma to any future
metaphysics Emmanuel Kant is going to to
engage in what he considers to be quite
important but not a matter of knowledge
about what he's going to call the
natural predisposition natur anaga of
human reason and this is speculations or
conjectures not something that we can
say is definite knowledge of the nature
of the pun intended of the topic and he
begins in section 60 saying we've
exhibited metaphysics according to its
subjective possibility as it is actually
given in the natural predisposition of
human reason and in that which
constitutes the essential end the Zac of
its Pursuit a term that's going to be
used quite a bit in this and he says
that you know the um merely natural use
of such a predisposition of our reason
if no discipline arising only from a
scientific critique bridles and sets
limits to it it gets us into
Transcendent dialectical inferences and
this is a problem right so we get a
fallacious metaphysics but then he
says there's still a problem worthy of
inquiry which is to find out the natural
ends the
N of what of this faculty that we have
and of this dis position this tendency
that reason possesses the natural ends
intended by this disposition to what
Transcendent not transcendental but
Transcendent
Concepts in our reason why why is you
know reason like this why does it think
about things that it can't really know
and he says that now this is a big kind
of assumption here
everything that lies in nature must be
originally intended for some useful
purpose or some some use some point to
it right and K will say then in the next
paragraph So this inquiry that we're
engaged in this unuk is doubtful
doubtful is a way of translating this
term mysik which also has connotations
of like you know irritating annoying
right and he tells us that this is only
conjecture uh M Mas right it's not
knowledge or cognition or anything like
that but it's conjecture about the ends
that nature would
have so he
says um it it you know this is
speculation about these first ends it
may be allowed to me in this case
alone why because we're not dealing with
the objective validity GTI kite of
metaphysical judgments but only our
natural
predisposition to them so if we can
approach this in a limited restrained
manner we're not going to fall into any
sort of problem and he says okay so when
I think about the transcendental ideas
the totality of which constitutes the
particular problem of natural pure
reason compelling it to quit the mere
contemplation of nature to transcend all
possible experience and in this endeavor
to produce the thing be it knowledge or
fiction called metaphysics I think so
this is Kant staking out a claim for
himself I think I perceive notice those
two modalities right that the aim of
this natural tendency is what what is
the point of it to free our Concepts the
concepts you know that we want to use
here from the Fetters the restrictions
of
experience and from the limits of the
mere contemplation of nature so we're
getting away from something right we're
getting away from
limitations and what's the positive then
so at least to open to us a field
containing mere objects for the pure
understanding which no sensibility no
Zite can
reach not indeed for so what is what is
the point of this um it is
to uh engage in Practical principles not
for the purpose of speculatively
occupying ourselves right but for
practical principles that would find
scope for their necessary expectation
and hope notice that term hope and might
expand to the universality which reason
requires from the moral point of view so
thinking about the these these
transcendental
ideas although we can't really make any
progress with them it frees up the moral
domain for conscient ethics for you know
the only kind of Ethics that God
considers truly valid and so how does it
do that well he's going to tell us and
he's going to do a review of these but
here's the Crux of it the transcendental
ideas are going to
destroy the
assertions and he you know he's got
these as sort of bad assertions impudent
and restrictive assertions of what of
three points of view philosophically
materialism naturalism and fatalism okay
so how does that happen well it has to
do with these three types of
transcendental ideas so he says the
psychological idea which doesn't really
tell me the nature of the human soul
Soul uh which is elevated above all
concepts of experience it shows the
insufficiency of these Concepts plainly
enough and thereby deters me from
materialism why because we see that
materialism is unfit for any explanation
of Nature and confines reason in
Practical respects so the psychological
idea properly explored gets rid of
materialism right not saying that
nothing's material of course but the
soul or the Consciousness can't
be what about the cosmological ideas
well we see that there's a particular
thing being targeted here the
cosmological ideas by the obvious
insufficiency of all possible cognition
of nature to satisfy reason in its
legitimate inquiry serve to keep us from
natur naturalism why because naturalism
asserts nature to be sufficient for
itself that is how Kant is understanding
this term
naturalism so because we for example
can't say that uh the universe actually
does have limits or boundaries or
doesn't neither of those are going to be
actually uh acceptable you know from the
point of view of of Reason considering
these well that shows us that there's a
kind of openness here a insufficiency
that we can look at what about the
theological
idea the ideal of pure reason as uh K
has called it all natural necessity in
the sensible world is conditional as it
is always presupposing the dependence of
things on others and unconditional
necessity must be sought only in the
unity of a cause different from the
world of sense but the causality of this
cause in its turn were it merely nature
could never render the existence of the
contingent as its consequent
comprehensible reason frees Itself by
means of the theological idea from
fatalism and how does Kant understand
fatalism so he says in two ways as a
blind natural necessity in the coherence
of nature itself without a first
principle and as a blind causality of
this principle itself and so that we're
led to uh the concept of a cause
possessing freedom and hence of a
supreme intelligence so this you know
natural predisposition of Reason which
leads us into the dialectic of pure
reason with these transc these
Transcendent Concepts um this winds up
freeing us from erroneous points of view
about ourselves the world and whatever
it is that's determining the world as a
whole now
one of the questions that we can ask
ourselves is is what Kant you know is
aiming at with all of these conjectures
is this really metaphysics and K says no
not specifically so he'll tell us in a
passage that I skipped over to reserve
it for right here that um because this
inquir is of a doubtful nature we're not
concerning the objective validity of
metaphysical judgments but our natural
predisposition he says
therefore this inquiry does not belong
to the system of metaphysics but to
anthropology now that may be a little
bit confusing if you are thinking in
terms of the Contemporary discipline of
anthropology which originally sprang
from philosophical anthropology but then
developed into all sorts of other things
as well doing ethnographic St studies
and playing around with you know burial
sites and all all this other sort of
stuff what Kant means by anthropology
here is a study a rigorous systematic
study of human beings as such as you
know rational creatures but also as
creatures of nature we are only one
potential kind of rational intelligence
right so when we're restricting
ourselves to anthropology saying how is
it for us human beings now a little bit
later he's going to talk about how the
dialectic of pure reason being
unavoidable considered in metaphysics as
a uh natural tendency he says it
deserves to be explained not as a mere
illusion but also as a natural
provision as regards its end though this
Tas ask and he calls this a work of
supererogation right the term there is
Uber now super arrogation means
literally asking for what is above right
so when we say going above and
beyond metaphysics doesn't have to mess
around with this stuff and so it's not
really metaphysics task it's something
else a
supererogatory task a super arog
calling to attain this
end then he's he's already talked about
this as a scolum right uh an extra
little bit and then he talks about a
second scholium which has a greater
Affinity with the subject of metaphysics
and let's take a a short look at this he
says there are certain rational
principles which determine opiary the
order of nature that of the
understanding which seeks nature's laws
through experience okay so so far so so
good they seem to be constituative and
legislative with regard to experience
though they spring from Mere reason
which cannot be considered like the
understanding as a principle of possible
experience so what we're looking at here
is how is how is the understanding and
reason actually related to each other
and he talks about a Harmony right and
then he talks about a thoroughgoing
unity in the use of the understanding to
bring about an entirety of all possible
experiences this can only belong to the
understanding when in relation to
reason with the result that experien is
in this way immediately subordinate to
the legislation of reason reason is
something which gives laws to itself and
to the world and also to its lower
faculties and so he says this question
may be discussed by those who desire to
trace the nature of Reason even Beyond
its use in metaphysics into general
principles now notice the the term he's
going to use here for making systematic
a history of nature in general and he
says this is an important task but I'm
not trying to do this in this work so
what would a history of nature in
general be we're not talking just about
history in the sense that we think about
it as you know a Chronicle of human
Affairs Natural History would be the
long history of nature itself but it
would not just be the the history of
things that we discover in the world
like you know how volcanoes work or
something like that because that's still
the realm of appearances right
representations we want to figure out
how this interesting Harmony for human
beings between reason which goes Way
Beyond experience and the understanding
which is applied to experience how does
this actually work and K says well this
is close to metaphysics but it's not
metaphysics per se and this is where he
leaves off in this conclusion so we have
an very interesting potential task set
of speculations or conjectures about
what what is the point of us sort of
inevitably going Beyond experience into
these ideas of pure reason and here's
kant's answer to
that